non-minimalists
i was wondering what you do as a
minimalist in terms of food
i like to cook and i was wondering if
you plan your meals by the week or by
the day
what do you do for restaurants is it a
spontaneous thing
so if i were to rephrase this question
another way and we can talk about the
dining out thing and
because i think that's important in fact
we'll bring ben and bex in to talk about
some of that as well
if i were to rephrase the question in a
way i would phrase it like this
what is the most minimalist diet
and i think that's the question that we
wrestle with
but also thinking that there's going to
be a prescription there with the answer
i don't have that but i want to read
this excerpt so
this is from love people use things it's
page 121
and this section is from the
relationship with self chapter so
of course for those of you listening is
you know the the book is seven different
relationships that we
want to heal in our lives the
relationship with stuff it starts with
the stuff
as the minimalists in this relationship
with the truth the relationship
with values relationship with money
relationship with creativity
eventually a relationship with people
but in between there there's the
relationship with
yourself which is quite often one of the
most difficult relationships to
repair because we've been lying to
ourselves we've also
gotten caught up in our own patterns
that are hard
very difficult to break and so in there
we talk about sleep we talk about
exercise we talk about
self-care we talk about being here
being present in the moment but then
there's also this section of
diet it's called a minimalist diet it
goes a little something like this
even now in the 21st century it's hard
for experts to agree on what's healthy
one website might recommend a paleo diet
the next a plant-based diet and another
a low-carb diet
after falling down the rabbit hole of
contradictory advice
we slam our laptop shut and return to
our deep fried oreos
which are totally vegan by the way
on an episode of the minimalist podcast
episode 184 minimalist diets
we hosted a discussion so that's diets
plural right
because we hosted a discussion between a
vegan athlete rich roll
who eats nothing but plants a carnivore
doctor
paul saladino md who eats nothing but
animals
that's not a typo and an omnivore doctor
thomas wood md who like 99
of the world eats both plants and
animals
although all three experts were shining
examples of health
they held radically different views
instead of playing host to a
debate i was more interested in what
these professionals agreed upon
despite their different approaches
everyone agreed that processed foods are
not ideal for a healthy life
nor is sugar gluten chemicals
refined oils or factory farming
they also agreed that every human being
is genetically unique
therefore two people might experience
completely different results
on the same diet no wonder health is so
complicated
what works for you might not work for me
that's exhausting so instead of
prescribing one
size fits all lifestyle it's best to
focus
on universal principles this is the
framework
for a healthy minimalist diet eat real
food
don't over or under eat avoid
inflammatory foods
keep away from refined oils such as
canola oil
vegetable oil soybean oil safflower oil
corn oils margarine and the like because
these oils
are refined by using chemicals that are
harmful to us
opt instead for healthy organic
alternatives like
extra virgin olive oil avocado oil
coconut oil and grass-fed butter or
tallow
don't eat foods that make you feel bad
man that could be like
that that's the minimalist diet right
there right don't eat foods that make
you feel bad
yeah the problem is what does that even
mean like so quite often a piece of cake
makes you feel great
from the gustatory pleasure during
mastication
yeah but it doesn't make you feel great
an hour from now a day from now whatever
you never look back or at least i never
look back
and say man i'm really glad i ate that
piece of cake three weeks ago
i'm never like really joyous about
having eaten that cake three weeks ago
it's not to say that i shouldn't eat it
i shouldn't enjoy it in the moment
but there's never gonna be a time in the
future where i'm like oh man i wish i
would have eaten more cake
three weeks ago yeah it just doesn't
happen uh three more things here
focus on the pro problem not the symptom
eat organic plants and grass-fed meats
buy local
whenever possible results may vary but a
sturdy framework allows us to build the
house that best suits our needs and
desires
by my mid-20s after doing my own
research no longer waiting for someone
to show up with a pill to fix my
problems i had changed my diet
to remove the causes of my obesity for
me
that meant eliminating sugar bread and
processed foods it also meant
eating many plants avoiding snacks
consuming only two meals a day
and fasting 16 hours a day it goes on to
talk about
the stewardship of the self and so when
we're talking about the minimalist diet
it's what ryan alluded to
earlier it's what do i cut out what do i
remove now
i just gave you a framework there this
isn't my framework by the way
but i'm interested on what i missed so
let's hear from
ben greenfield about what i missed and
also
some different approaches to a
minimalist diet what am i missing here
wow drop your mic
uh what are you missing well uh
related to the concept of minimalism
i could throw a few other chips in there
perhaps although that's that's really
comprehensive like i think i probably
agree with nearly everything
in there aside from the fact i was
surprised that
everyone who you'd interviewed had
thrown in gluten as something that was
bad
yeah just because you'll find a lot of
plant-based people are like well it's
it's maybe disruptive to your stomach
but it's not like as bad as somebody
like
let's say paul saladino would say that
it is and i even think that gluten in
trace amounts is kind of like a little
bit of a hormetic
compound for the body not gluten in
modern processed
gmo wheat where it's super concentrated
but like i'm not gluten free
but for me you know that might be a
slice of lovely
fermented sourdough bread where much of
the gluten has been you know
pre-digested et cetera
um but aside from that super nit-picky
point yeah
and i think that's why it it
specifically i use the word avoid as
opposed to eliminate
there are some foods where it makes
sense to eliminate right
they're not even foods they are food
products the deep fried twinkies
they were oreos but the twinkies are
okay
that's a minnesota cookies have fiber
see um so so yeah what would i throw in
first of all from a from a minimalist
standpoint
um and and related to the question that
our dear listener asked and i forgot in
her name
her name's sarah sarah uh first of all i
eat nearly the same thing every day
for breakfast for lunches and for any
beverages or snacks
down to nearby no no
it's not mcdonald's and i'm not saying
that everyone's same meals
per day need to be the same as everyone
else's but
i down to almost the near exact time
that i eat each day and the meal that i
eat each day until about
7 p.m when we eventually sit down to our
wonderful glorious family dinner where
we're experimenting with all sorts of
new foods or we maybe have a whatever a
giant loin of of beef in the freezer and
we want to try out
some new recipe with it and so every
night is like fun
and varied and you know it's always some
kind of meat some kind of vegetable some
kind of starch
but uh yeah every single day you know
it's typically for me a smoothie for
breakfast and some kind of a
salad with some healthy fats almost like
a mediterranean style salad for
lunch and typically you know a giant
mason glass of water full of
wonderful things like vitamin c and
baking soda in the morning and another
one
kind of in the afternoon a cup of coffee
at some point in there in between waking
and breakfast and it's so i have very
little decision-making fatigue
when it comes to my meals and i'm happy
as a clam like
just doing that same thing every day so
that'll be the first thing is just
minimalist in terms of the variety of
meals that you eat
on a similar vein i stay relatively
minimalist
with my preparation techniques of choice
meaning that if you know how to really
use a few cool tools in the kitchen
you're kind of set for life and you
don't have to beat yourself up about not
having an infrared
fryer and a pressure cooker and the
slope
crock pot and the food dehydrator and
the two different
varieties of food processors so for me
i generally cook with a sous-vi wand
very small sous-vi wand water bath
meaning you put the water or you put the
food in in a bag you put it in the water
you set it to temperature you walk away
you come back and whatever you you know
take a piece of salmon throw some dill
some salt some pepper maybe some thyme
or rosemary in there put it in the bag
walk away come back have dinner
right so so i use yeah yeah i use the
sous vide
i use uh a grill right that's right on
my back and i have one of the electronic
grills
this this podcast is not sponsored by
anyone so so i won't say the name of the
grill but
but it smokes it'll tie to my phone to
where i can just same thing adjust the
temperature and walk away so i like
these kind of minimalist cooking
techniques
and the last one is a pressure cooker
same thing
put the food in walk away you know fall
off the bone
ribs that melt in your mouth that would
normally take four hours on a grill
i can do in a pressure cooker in 30
minutes and so i'm pretty minimalist
with my cooking techniques it's usually
sous vide
pressure cooker or grill
and then a couple of other tips i would
say because
because she asked about the restaurants
before the restaurants the other thing i
would say
is from a minimalist standpoint if
you're trying to minimize calories
which might actually fall into into a
minimizing point of view for a lot of
people
i try to choose a lot of foods that fill
me up but that aren't very calorie dense
so these would be things like um there
there's this
this type of uh japanese noodle called
conten it's like a
gel-like noodle that kind of expands in
your stomach it tastes like you're
eating pasta they make the angel hair
variety and the pasta variety
i use this brand called miracle noodle
it's zero calories zero carbs but it's
like
i can have pasta or i can serve my
lunchtime salad up on top of this stuff
and it fills me up another one that i
i'll give you three that i go through
quite a bit like staples for me because
again i eat the same thing and you know
i open them up my refrigerator these are
always in there
um the next one is cmos gel same thing
it's incredibly filling it's somewhat
nutrient dense
a very low in calories and that's
something that
rather than say putting a bunch of extra
coconut milk in a smoothie right to
thicken it up and give it that creamy
texture
which would be 250 extra calories i'll
use a couple scoops of
cmos gel which gives me the same
thickening effect with
none of the calories and then the last
one that i like is
i love pumpkin puree i buy like organic
pumpkin puree from amazon like the stuff
you'd use to make pumpkin pie
but i will just like put a big old
spoonful of that on a plate and sprinkle
out with a little salt maybe a small
drizzle of honey
a little bit of cinnamon and it's almost
like i have like this edible pumpkin pie
like baby food mash that i can eat while
i'm having lunch
and so i'm kind of a minimalist when it
comes to trying to choose
staple ingredients that are actually
relatively low in calories
but have a satiating effect of a higher
calorie compound not quite as good as a
deep-fried oreo but
you know deep fried i went out over the
cmos gel and then the the question
regarding restaurants
um so yes we do plan restaurant outings
i actually plan typically two months in
advance
for all restaurant outings and all
dinner parties because i know how
quickly evenings fill up and i know how
quickly reservations fill up
so typically on the calendar is once
each month a date with my wife
once each month a date with each of my
boys who are 13 and who are
a little bit different when you take
them out individually than when when
they're with mom and the other brother
you know that it's great conversations
when you're with a child
one-on-one so i would challenge any
parent out there if you're not yet
dating your children one-on-one
do it and then in addition to
do it the monthly date with my wife uh
the monthly dates with each of my boys
uh we then schedule two dinner parties
each month in which
we have people over to our house and
this would be a wide variety of people
from the local community people i've
been wanting to get to know but haven't
yet met
people who are old family friends
sometimes family members sometimes
employees
uh sometimes literally um people who
you know the last party you know this
guy walked off the street like this
homeless
kid into my boys jiu jitsu gym and got a
job there he wound up coming up with his
jiu jitsu coach you know so we got a you
know some
you know spokane exec on one side and
this you know homeless kid from the
jujitsu gym on the other side
and we just throw these dinner parties
where we bring people together
and i i provide all the meat and
everyone usually just springs aside
um and then ever so occasionally if i'm
feeling really lazy
i will move that dinner party out to a
local restaurant
you know if we just know we don't want
to clean up the next morning but
but that's kind of how i how i do the
restaurant thing so i actually plan it
in advance and i know
what i'm going to do at restaurants and
and when and who's going did you enjoy
this video
if so you can listen to full episodes of
the minimalist private podcast available
exclusively on
patreon visit patreon.com the
minimalists today
your support keeps our podcast and
youtube channel 100
advertisement free